lawmakers on Capitol Hill today will
focus on two issues with long-term
consequences the senate continues a rare
open ended debate on immigration reform
congress has less than three weeks to
replace the daca program protecting
young undocumented immigrants and the
president's budget director will try to
sell congress on a new budget framework
for next year
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill to
unpack all this for us so Nancy what are
the priorities do you think in the
President's budget well they certainly
want to enact some cuts to domestic
programs whether they'll be able to do
that remains to be seen certainly the
budget director Mick Mulvaney is going
to make the case today in conversations
with members of both the House and the
Senate he is going to sit down with them
and go over this plan which calls for
four point four trillion dollars in
federal spending in 2018 and 2019
setting aside 18 billion dollars for a
border wall and about two hundred
billion dollars for infrastructure but
the proposal would also cut about five
hundred billion dollars over ten years
from Medicare and about two hundred
billion from the program that provides
food stamps even with those cuts the
budget would still add about seven
trillion to the deficit by 2028 which is
something that some fiscal conservatives
will find difficult to handle now the
reality is that the Senate struck a
budget agreement last week that would
cover the next two years so the chances
that any of this is going to get turned
into legislation and then into law is
pretty slim right now Gail a lot of work
to do there but Nancy here's a question
for you mitch mcconnell's opening up the
Senate this week to an immigration
debate do you think that they could
reach an agreement what's the thinking
on the hill well they're going to hold a
series of votes over the next couple of
days on partisan and bipartisan issues
for example one of the first amendments
up is going to be this proposal from a
trio of Republican senators cotton
Grassley and Cornyn that allows a path
to citizenship for these so-called
dreamers in exchange for increased
border security and some changes to
immigration rules that Democrats are you
will severely limit the number of legal
immigrants who are allowed to enter the
u.s. those Democrats say they do not
believe
this plan can get the sixty votes needed
in frankly jail there's a lot of
pessimism right now that any of these
plans will get the sixty votes necessary
to advance whatever comes out of the
Senate to the house all right Nancy
Cordes thank you very much